[Music]
but pantomime is one of the longest
election campaigns in world politics
formally started again on Tuesday with
the Democratic Party's Iowa caucus in
the United States now the caucus turned
out to be a bit of a shambles but the
current favorites to be the Democratic
presidential candidate have three
similar characteristics they are all
male all white and most bizarre of all
they are all in their late 70s the 78
year old Bernie Sanders the 77 year old
Joe Biden I'm waiting in the wings ready
to join the battle later in the month
he's another sexagenarian the former
mayor of New York billionaire Michael
Bloomberg who is also age 77 and of
course the three of them are battling it
out to run against Donald Trump a mere
youngster it just 73 isn't this all
faintly ridiculous
I can understand it if all these three
old white blokes were fighting it out to
be president of the local golf club
there was a minimum age to run for
president in the US you have to be at
least 35 isn't it time they bought in a
maximum age as well say 70 the trouble
is if you did none of the current
favorites would qualify
so my opinion on this is that actually
age shouldn't play a troll there's some
80 roles that have the physiology of a
20 year old you know out there running
man at marathons running companies I
don't think age should actually play a
role in that and actually another
interesting part of that is do you say
there's the minimum age of 35 I think
that's wrong as well I think it's about
how talented you are as you know a
leader your you know your credibility
and how you know many people really
believe in what you're saying I went to
here Baroness Hale who was on a Supreme
Court justice give a lecture at my old
college this week and she said that all
the attempts to increase diversity and
so on and so forth and women's women's
representation of a lot of that sort of
thing falls foul of the Discrimination
Act and so does actually discriminating
on grounds of age so I think that here
you couldn't say you can't say in a job
advert you can't be over 70 and I don't
think it's right to say it either I
rather like the fact that we're seeing
these men in the twilight of their years
trying to do the biggest job in the
world you can no longer make people
retire of course so you get people
hanging on in jobs long after they
should be there because and my views it
doesn't surprise me that my generation
because you know I'm over 70 my
generation when they got who were the
baby boomers and always and everything
all the way to the late 60s and change
the law so you couldn't make them
because well but if you come back to to
the United States there's no doubt in my
mind I did some quite big jobs in this
country and I've got to tell you I
couldn't do them in my 70s and I think
Jimmy Carter said he couldn't age 8 he
couldn't do the job of President age 70
didn't he yeah what do you think well I
have to tell you this is being taped on
Thursday the 6th of February which
famous American president would have
been 109 today where he still alive
I speak of one of the greatest
presidents of all time Ronald Reagan who
didn't get to power until he was 70 so
he might have had about half an hour
under your laws need about to go under
my not allowed to stay for the ages I
would and of course they'll be very many
people watching this who thing whose
actions he bought about an extraordinary
economic turnaround for the United
States of America I think he was a force
for good
for world peace certainly for European
peace he prob might not got under your
bar I have to find for Erick's and I
find against you on this occasion and I
have to say I don't agree with you
either
I do think you know if you looked and
there was a stack and where it is now he
is looking at Americans and what kind of
age they wanted ideally their President
to be there's very tiny percentage that
said that they actually wanted them to
be over the age of 70 so I think is a
failing in the screening process where
you're out put your candidates they are
predominantly old white men for me I'd
be sitting there going what's wrong with
my screening process that that is the
outputs I've been looking at from that
perspective however I don't think it's
fair to dictate someone as opportunity
in life based purely on a numerical age
because as Alex quite rightly said you
know I know some 24 year olds that have
the energy you know of like a snail and
I nurses measure that would matter would
be their age but I do also disagree with
you when you say that they shouldn't be
a minimum age because I think if you
want to lead a country you have to have
had some form of life experience and on
that point they need that what the
person is leading the pack for the
Democrats is Pete now we're trying to
work out I had footage call him mayor
Pete who's I think 38 39 and he served
in the military and he's studied here
and he's also been to Harvard I think it
matters more than age is experience
let's take a look at this pledges this
is for the upcoming presidential
election
and how Donald Trump fares against the
prominent Democrats Joe Biden there we
are biting so it does seem to underscore
that Americans prefer the older man Joe
Biden is up 6 points then against Bernie
Sanders Sanders wins by 4 against
Elizabeth Warren Warren is up by 3 and
then against my friend Pete the mayor
Pete Buddha check he's up by one thanks
to NBC News and Wall Street Journal for
that so it does seem to underscore it
comes back to your point doesn't that if
people have their eye on the older man
or the older woman and that's what they
want the chop the opportunity should be
there absolutely actually when I think
about this discussion I think back to my
experience in A&E you know the
consultants have been around for 20 30
years some of them are maybe a bit older
but they've have so much experience
they've seen so much in A&E that they
stand back and they watch what's
happening and they can just jump in and
say well actually does it at the moment
I don't think you I think it's very much
depends on your appraisal and
revalidation but I don't I mean the
problem the problem in the whole people
can stay on beyond when they have I
think the capacities necessary to do it
and a person who's got some kind of
health ailment
what do you do then so they take yeah
but they take your box in terms of the
age so yeah you're allowed in because
you're a 50 but if you've got some kind
of I don't know as chronic illness to
you then judging cold actually I think
your chronic illness is going to rule
you out so you can't come in either like
where do you draw the line but I think
Jimmy Carter's point is the VY one that
actually he looks back at he's like what
is in there he said when I was 78 or I
couldn't have done these things I did it
when I was young in that place he didn't
do that well before you know I think
it's very difficult now what was it
about Reagan was he he was brilliant and
offloading everything to other people a
bit because you've run a lot of
companies and you know
denieth artists in all honesty I think
that might make me a little bit nervous
there is a there's at a certain point
you won't be able to do the job because
you you know restricted by your ability
to do that your physiology and stuff but
it's that point then you obviously and
most people would go actually I can't
yeah I can't do this but not everyone's
the same some people at 70 you know very
capable as said might be running a
marathon or whatever and 23rd year olds
have any energy at all so it's
individual case don't age as a defining
limit right there choice about when they
can't do it was it somebody else's
choice and the danger is that some of
the people who could continue to do it
will lead and some with the sweep of
democratic candidates Greg I know you'll
celebrate like me and Michelle shell and
caucus is estranged Trump tweeted after
the Iowa caucuses and he was exonerated
a rolling thing saying Trump in 24 22 20
Trump in 24 Trump in 28 Trump in 32
Trump wants to go on forever